episode 6 of loki for all time always
has introduced kang the conqueror and
will probably change the face of the mcu
forever
here's the ending of loki episode 6
explained
the citadel at the end of time is a
truly bizarre place filled with ruined
statues of the time keepers
and ominous looking details the creepy
design of the building looks more like
something out of harry potter than the
mcu which makes it even weirder when
miss minutes appears out of nowhere
she's not the overarching villain of the
series but she's certainly not good
either
as it turns out the animated clock is
the direct line to a mysterious
individual she refers to as he who
remains
once again the mcu has taken something
from the comics and repurposed it for
the ongoing franchise
he who remains is in charge of the time
variance authority in the source
material
even meeting thor and jane foster in
thor number 245
back in 1976 however when he arrives on
screen in loki it's instantly clear that
he who remains in the mcu is actually a
variant of kang the conqueror
played by none other than jonathan
magers who recently broke out as the
star of lovecraft country
major's casting as kang was previously
revealed by deadline in september 2020
in a report claiming he'll be the
villain in ant-man and the wasp
spontamania although how he'll go up
against the mcu's tiniest hero remains
to be seen
if you're up on your mcu casting news
it's instantly clear who this mysterious
purple-robed individual is once major's
character steps out of an elevator to
meet sylvian loki
majors clearly has a lot of fun with the
role and he has a pretty chaotic
presence which rivals the god of
mischief himself
however in yet another twist he's not
exactly the version of kang the
conqueror that fans might be familiar
with
while other mcu disney plus shows like
wandavision and the falcon and the
winter soldier featured action-packed
finales loki takes a quieter approach
it mainly revolves around the universe
breaking conversation between this kang
variant loki and sylvie about the true
nature of the tva the sacred timeline
and the multiverse war
essentially it prepares audiences for
jonathan major's ongoing role within the
mcu is king the conqueror
because as he who remains explains he's
but one of the countless variants of the
villain that exists throughout the
multiverse
essentially he who remains is using the
tva and elia to keep the sacred timeline
flowing as he thinks it should
which ensures that the universe doesn't
fall into yet another multiverse war
the war itself was once upon a time
waged by different kang variants who
originally united for the good of every
universe only to ultimately betray one
another and fight for one timeline
supremacy
in the comics this alliance was called
the council of kangs and they've been
around for centuries
he who remains even alludes to this in
the episode saying that he's been called
many names over time
a ruler a conqueror
he who remains a jerk
interestingly the kang we see in loki
bears more of a resemblance to immortus
the older somewhat wiser kang variant
who pops up in the comics as sort of a
cosmic gardener of the marvel time
stream
regardless where do loki and sylvia fit
into all of this
he who remains says he's been pulling
the strings on them from the very start
dictating their lives so that they both
arrive at this meeting however the
seemingly all-knowing villain doesn't
actually
well know it all his knowledge of the
timeline only goes up to a certain point
stating that once it crossed that
threshold anything loki and sylvie do is
out of his control
that's when the sacred timeline begins
splintering all around the citadel
coincidence surely not this revelation
forces
loki and sylvia into a fight as they
grapple with the choice of killing he
who remains for creating the tba and
snatching free will away from the
timeline or
taking over the tba themselves sylvia is
all for killing him straight away
because her goal from the start of the
show has been to tear down the tva and
those who run it so it's understandable
that she wants revenge for the life that
was snatched away from her
however loki clearly recognizes the
bigger potential danger of another
multiverse war and the other kang
variants that are out there
leading to a brief duel but the romantic
tension between these two is palpable
especially when sylvie passionately
kisses loki
in fact loki has clearly pushed aside
his own goals of domination for her
i just want you to be okay unfortunately
the kiss was self-serving for sylvie who
uses it to distract
loki in order to hurl him through a time
door she may call herself sylvie but
she's still a loki
and that means manipulation from the
very beginning sylvie's been on a
journey of her own and will not
compromise for anything or anyone
ultimately she stabs he who remains and
he dies in his chair
of course this isn't even close to the
end for jonathan majors before he dies
the villain whispers
[Music]
basically get ready to see a whole ton
of different kangs in the mcu
and that's the last we see of sylvie for
now
the tva took a bit of a back seat in
this episode but clearly the agency will
never be the same again as hunter b-15
finds the original ravana red slayer in
a school in 2018
ohio to convince the rest of her fellow
hunters that everyone in the tva is
actually a variant
it's a pretty shocking revelation but
clearly the tva hasn't torn itself apart
because they're all still watching the
sacred timeline splinter beyond repair
by the end of the episode
meanwhile the tba's version of ravana
disappeared early in the episode to
search for free will
whatever that means when loki crashes
back through the time door he
frantically tries to warn mobius about
he who remains
and the threat of an impending
multiverse war but when he finally
tracks his friend down and begins
talking mobius stops him and asks him
what his name
is how are you what's your name
wow clearly loki has ended up in an
alternate version of the tva and a
variant king has already messed with the
timeline
changing events in the past to change
the status quo and loki's present
that's confirmed by the towering statue
of the villain in a pretty comic book
accurate version of his costume at the
center of the tva complex
as fans may already know kang's reach
spans across millennia so changing the
past to put himself in a supreme
position of power isn't much of a
surprise luckily with loki's season 2
already greenlits we'll have plenty of
time to see how the god of mischief
tackles this new timeline
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu projects are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one